how long till you pay off that that's
for you hey you got a butt chug it chug
it
I'll bet I think we'll get kicked off
YouTube have a butt chug it No everybody
wants how long until you pay off that
nice my ex-wife just sent in a question
what did she text you yes did you have
sex in prison it's a good question yeah
yeah my sit by myself um then she said
did you meet and marry your ex-wife just
to piss off Eddie sir Alice which was
the guy that was dating my ex-wife when
I'm Eddie or else was dating her she's
going that was my blondie question that
was my boss not us so he he's dating
this chick Kayla Burgos and she comes in
and he to get a mortgage she applies for
a mortgage I know he's dating her but
he's also engaged to some some chick so
I'm like I start hitting on her and
she's like I'm dating I'm dating Eddie
and I'm like yeah but it pisses off his
[ __ ] fiancee so I was thinking maybe
that's not gonna work out for you so
anyway I bet I keep asking her out I
asked her out like probably four or five
times over the next two weeks and
eventually she is okay she is yeah we'll
go out but she was also turns out she
was the she worked at the bank I banked
with and checked my bank account and
then decided yeah I'll go out with you
after she checked how much money I was
depositing every month and that's not
just me she'll tell you that so I'm just
saying you know that [ __ ] did you have
sex in prison no will you stop did you
have sex in prison [ __ ] shut the [ __ ]
up that's what you get that's what
happens everybody wants to a need a
shotgun a beer that's the only kind of
content you can get right here live on
concrete Wow
yeah set it off oh this is great it's
great it was good now yeah Matt I got
another question question bubby main man
did you ever utilize the dark web during
your times a frog I've read that
question no there was no there was no
dog I wasn't out back I don't think
there was a dark well that was back in
2006 November 16 2006 that was before
the Internet
that's fine I won't come next time all
right I got another one Matt from
Michael Rodriguez have you ever ran into
someone you've scanned before if so how
did the situation occur and how did they
react I've never you know never scammed
anybody like what you know like maybe
the names you used I was just misses
there was a guy named you saw him it
like the Walgreen no I meant I'm never
saw like like like there was a guy there
was a guy named Scott cugno and I used
his identity and I actually got like
what I was doing research on my book I
actually got documents in where they
talked about talking to him and going to
him and saying they'd knock on his door
and they're just like so I'm like the
Marshalls or the FBI yeah they like show
him like my picture there he's like
that's Matt Cox they're like well he
just used your identity to cash like
four hundred thousand dollars worth of
checks he's like so I've always wondered
if I bumped into him what he'd say you
know I feel bad I gotta get him on cuz I
I knew him he was at a count rep I
actually the way I got his information
we've done a loan for his for him so I
had his date of birth social security
number so I had his date of birth social
security number but I didn't have his
mother's maiden name and the place of
birth
so I I end up talking I ended up saying
hey so Scott what's up how's it going
he's like oh what's up how's the guy
said hey say hi oh Scud no I go cugno
Eagle what is that German is that any
and he goes no no it's English and I go
oh are you are you 100% or whatever it
was you know it's it's scotch or
whatever you know it's it's Italian
whatever it was and I go oh how to
proceed he goes no I said what's your
mom's last name because oh my mom's last
name boom just blurts it out Balkan I
got your mom's last name and I go so
were you born here and in Florida and he
goes yeah I was born right here in
Hillsborough kind of like okay boom all
right now I got everything I got your
name date of birth social security
number and I have your mom's maiden name
we don't even need to talk anymore so
I'm slick son of a [ __ ] he actually was
telling me a story about how his parents
met as I was ordering the documents to
steal his identity I'm sitting talking
to me I'm downloading the Hillsborough
County application for your birth
certificate
I ran out while he's talking about
filling it out while he's telling what
that is a funny story that is a funny
story and I fold it up and I send off
the [ __ ] and a week later I had I feel
bad about that don't don't judge me I'm
not that and I like Scott Scott's a nice
guy you know I need everybody to buy a
book there's some books I go over all
this in front of where we went in print
and nobody's Amazon and on me and Amazon
Amazon bro
Amazon yeah is it on Kindle it's on
Kindle and I have a guy who's turning it
into an audible right now and they want
they want you baby daughter boy yeah I
really want you to read it I got a ton
of them I want you I want your voice
listen
he can't read like a fourth grader yes
have you yeah he's heard me it's
embarrassing it is it's everybody this
table reads like a fourth grader you've
heard him reading question nobody like
they're like oh it doesn't matter that
you haven't heard me read you can do it
you don't know it's bad so I can't read
the [ __ ] book and still it doesn't
even matter
trusty not with this attitude and the
dislike alright let's move on to the
next one
alright let me check on the crab where's
my crab
we got better J what was his favorite
book he has written and will he be doing
more podcasts what one what is the
favorite your favorite book you've
written AHA what second part will you be
doing more podcasts [ __ ] is teetering
right now can you zoom in on Shane's
face on the camera no you can't I'm
trying to think my favorite book yeah
bro right in my book was hard that's
hard like writing it cuz your own story
yes don't sorry exactly his favorite
sociopath
so narcissus but also see about to you
probably but the point is what's my you
know what honestly I really liked
writing cuz it's hilarious
and everybody just read it which is only
been a few people cuz I have been like
publicized it at all even mention it is
a book I wrote called
called the program which is about me and
prison it's only like a hundred and ten
pages but it's on Amazon - what's it
about it's about me being in prison and
I was it's like the last couple years I
was in prison when I knew I was getting
out I'm writing a bunch of guys stories
that I keep going into the drug program
so they won't ship me to a camp because
my mom came over two weeks so the
closest it if Coleman is Coleman it's a
low security place yeah and it's only an
hour away from Tampa hmm my mom drove
there every two weeks so what happens is
I was so close to the door and my points
were so low that the Bo P kept saying we
have to ship you to a camp you have low
you have camp points mm-hmm and I kept
saying I didn't want to go well
eventually they said we're shipping you
well the only way to keep me there at
the low was to get what's called a
management variable put on you and they
like if you're in an education program
they won't ship you so and they're good
for a year so I go I say look I can't
you can't ship me I'm going in the drug
program I have a drug problem so and
they're like well if you go in the drug
program yeah we'll we'll have to keep
you here so I go in the drug
gram and they they put a management
variable on me but it takes a month or
so so by the time they when the
management variable comes on me I
immediately drop out of the program it's
supposed to be good for a year yeah
three months later they call me and say
look we're taking the management
variable off you were sending you to a
camp I'm like what are you talking about
it's supposed to be good for a year and
they go yeah but coughs there's a real
push to get you guys like you in two
camps and you shouldn't be here and I'm
like no no I got a problem with drugs I
got to go back to the drug program and
they're like well you dropped out I'm
like I know but I didn't realize how bad
it was and you know III need to face
this I you should it was so [ __ ] bad
I mean I I totally put a hold it I sold
it like they're like okay well if you
really do you really need it home like I
do and so I go back in again for four or
five months till they put the put it
back on me and then I drop out again but
it's B I went nine months of the program
and the [ __ ] program is hilarious I
mean it's what it's doing because it's
it's a it's not a drug program it's a
it's a cognitive thinking program where
they're trying to retrain the way
criminals think so they're trying to fix
your criminal thinking so you have
criminal thinking errors or pattern
errors or whatever they call them
they're trying to mate rye and fix it so
there's there's a whole program based on
it so you're I'm there and these other
guys like if you can go through the
program and you can get through and
graduate you get a year off your
sentence but I'm so close to the door I
don't have time to get a year off my
sentence so if I'd gone through the
first time I we've got maybe six or
seven months off and and and that would
have been great six or seven months but
I was like look if I [ __ ] if I get if I
[ __ ] up and go back to prison I'm gonna
need that year I'll go to the program if
I come back they give me three years
I'll go in the program then and get a
year knock it off and get six months
halfway house we'll be right back out
the door so I'm not gonna do it now what
if I have to come save that one so what
do they do to alter your criminal
cognition or ever has you do things
which are called like our essays which
are um oh god was at an RSA this is a
rational self analysis where you as soon
as something happens you go through
these steps in your mind what you know
what it
they keep oh you you think like a normal
person a criminal doesn't think like you
do like you think if I jumped up right
now so [ __ ] you and threw something in
your face you might immediately be like
but before
do anything you're probably going okay
where do my altar what what are the my
possible choices if I do this then the
cops come and this happens and this
happens this happens next you know the
bubble and then you immediately think I
have a child I have I have a wife I have
bills I have this so before you know
you're like you know [ __ ] you Cox just
get out but a criminal doesn't think
like that
he's he's a criminal thing I'm gonna
kill you and [ __ ] the consequences I'll
go to prison I don't even think about
the consequences because I'm gonna get
away with it you know so it teaches them
to slow down and calcul calculate all
your the thoughts that normal people
take for it take for granted these guys
you know they don't think like that so
they have all these little things that
you do and they explain they go through
why did you commit crimes or why did you
do drugs why did you so you kind of
really get into all the different all
the different reasons that you are
committing criminal acts and the other
thing is they all held each other
accountable they take everybody that is
in this goes to the program and put them
in one unit so you got 150 guys who are
all holding each other accountable which
means that if I see if I see Shane
smoking pot in the [ __ ] bathroom then
in the morning meeting there's 150 guys
in the morning meaning we're all sitting
there facing each other you know rat
each other out right no it's holding you
accountable so cuz I care about you I'm
I know it seems like the wrong thing to
do but I'm looking out for you Shane
you're not taking your program seriously
you're not taking your your therapy
seriously sorry right more than that I'm
really sorry you have to stand up in
front of everybody they say look here's
what you did wrong here's what you're
not taking you seriously you you've made
these errors you should have done this
and here's what you need to do to
correct your behavior and then they give
you assignments that's what I hate it
you want to pull me up and say Matt you
were rude the other day I saw you do
this I saw you do that you mouthed off
to some guy okay fine I'll it's funny
that's true but then it's like basically
to fix this you need to do this you need
to write a letter home to your family
and tell them what you did that you
jeopardize your program and your one
year off you need to go around to five
or 20 different people and
there get there their take on how you
behaved you need to next thing you know
you got five [ __ ] hours worth of work
to do I'm trying to write a book bro
I mean I got you got me taking classes
you got me to the meetings you got me I
gotta memorize cards I'm trying to write
I hated it but it's comical guys get
into fights in the bathroom guys are
[ __ ] swinging on each other we were
there one time you got a guy who's there
for like cheating the IRS like he lied
on his taxes he got like three years he
stands up he's caught this guy smoking
k2 yeah in the bathroom like twice now
this is a guy whose mom is sick and
she's probably gonna die if he doesn't
get the year off and get out he's let
everybody know anybody phones me up I'm
gonna [ __ ] beat their asses I'm sure
I got to get out of here but he's also
an idiot cuz he's still smoking k2 so
this nice guy who's like a CEO stands up
he's like 60 years old stands up this is
a gang member by the way he's like a
crypt or a blood from from Hawaii who's
already been to beat in the state twice
on murder charges happens to be here on
a drug conspiracy he stands up in the
morning meaning I'd like to pull up
mister mister whatever his name was
oh the other night I saw you smoking pot
in the bathroom again our k2 Amanda you
know and and and so he starts giving in
the you know telling them you got to do
this and this and this and then he does
it and then they give you have something
called the damaging consequences the
damaging consequences to your behavior
are in the guys I got you're damaging
consequences all six-foot-two he swings
on him he punches the guys like it's
chaos 150 guys are jumping he's swinging
and he's punching this guy's hitting
this guy
it was [ __ ] hilarious I mean I was
never in danger I'm fightin I'm forty
feet away I wasn't in the mix so you're
writing a story in your head oh the
whole time I was there I was like oh
this has got to go so I have all this is
in the book it's in the book it's
hilarious
guys are getting caught having sex in
the bathroom guys are smoking dope guys
are there's drinking hooch there they're
threatening to kill each other like Oh
like I'm gonna have to pull you up
tomorrow he's like you do that I'll beat
you to [ __ ] death in your sleep
[ __ ] they're like oh
[Laughter]